quoi c'est mérité voici les qualités que
crohn allez y à notre peuple
souvenez vous à chaque instant tout
c'est le saut de rome qui a fait d'eux
le des barbares les meilleurs guerriers
de méthane yayi et j'y arrive mardi par
bas pour entreprendre une quête c'est
plus utile d'avoir des grosses burnes
que d'avoir des gros muscles
une fois que tu as trouvé que c'était un
vrai mec une quête c'est marrant et ça
va tu es un ennemi des patines au [ __ ]
c'est quoi ça
des feux d'artifice
tantôt honda reprend mais moi d'aller
sauver les autres quoi promet le bois ça
gaze alibert barbe
je suis trop content qu'on parte
enquêtent ensemble alors de règles pour
ce voyage
1 il ne s'agit pas d'une quête et 2 si
jamais on tombe sur un truc qui fait
penser à quelque chose qui ressemble à
une quête vont faire montreux détour
immédiatement qu'est ce que t'as branler
moi personne des sapins sont les elfes
jamais le sommeil et erg
damien le temps pour une petite danse
et là
elle se fera
non
qu'ils soient peinés triton aura qu
promenons nous dans l'aura pendant que
le bout et droit